RICHARD GINGRAS: I'm so
delighted to do this.
I'm Richard Gingras,
Senior Product Director
for News and Social.
I've known Anna
for, I don't know,
three, four, five years
now, and it's just
always been a pleasure
spending time with you,
both for the
crispness of your mind
and the wonderful appeal
of your sense of humor.
So--
ANNA HOLMES: Thank you.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Thank you.
And that obviously--
ANNA HOLMES: Thanks
for having me.
RICHARD GINGRAS: --that
always shows in what you do.
But it's great to have you here.
ANNA HOLMES: Thank you.
RICHARD GINGRAS: So recently,
Anna published-- just
came out with a book,
"The Book of Jezebel."
But I thought today,
we'd actually talked
about a bit more than.
We'll talk about "The
Book of Jezebel,"
but I also want to talk about
Jezebel in and of itself.
One of things that occurs
to me, as I think many of us
in this room know,
is as we've seen
very dramatic changes
in the underlying media
ecosystem, that
creates opportunities,
and, indeed, the need, on the
part of traditional publishers,
to figure out how do
they create products
appropriate for this medium.
And in a similar fashion, as
cultures change and evolve,
there are also
opportunities for new voices
to appear and address
those cultural changes
with the audiences that
are affected by them.
I think the interesting
thing about homes in Jezebel
is that in founding Jezebel
she's really done both.
Both, being considerably
hard, figuring out
what kind of product
can work in this realm,
and Jezebel has,
indeed, and continues
to work in this realm.
And also, in figuring out how
to address a media landscape
with an approach that makes
sense for the new culture,
for the evolving culture.
And in that, with
Jezebel, she created,
a site which was
unapologetic in its politics
and its sensibilities,
provocative, funny, insightful,
sometimes profane.
Anna, I know, hoped
that it would be,
and I believe, to
an extent, it has,
but I'll have you address that
at some point, an antidote
to the historical superficiality
in a relevance of women's media
properties.
A little bit of her background,
and then we'll start getting
into the why's and where's.
Because you weren't born with
a silver spoon in your mouth.
You were--
ANNA HOLMES: Uh-uh.
RICHARD GINGRAS: --born in
Sacramento, raised in Davis.
I believe your mom
was a schoolteacher,
your dad a park ranger in
the National Park Service.
In the late '90s you went to
New York, started out, as a--
ANNA HOLMES: Actually,
in the early '90s.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Early '90s.
ANNA HOLMES: I'm
older than you think.
[LAUGHTER]
RICHARD GINGRAS:
Started out as an intern
at "The New Yorker." you worked
at places like "Glamour,"
"Entertainment Weekly," "HBO."
All, I think, good
experiences for you
to understand at least the
traditional media environment.
And then went off to do
what you did with Jezebel.
You left Jezebel
in 2010, and then
went on to do the
book of Jezebel, which
if you haven't looked at it,
it's really a wonderful book.
And its, I think, both
seriously irreverent
and irreverently serious.
As, I think, befits the brand.
And by the way, I don't
know if you noticed,
but you actually now get
a Google auto suggest,
if you type in "Anna Holmes is."
ANNA HOLMES: Oh.
[LAUGHTER]
ANNA HOLMES: God.
Why would you do that? [LAUGH]
RICHARD GINGRAS: I did.
I did.
But so far, all good,
because all it says
is Anna Holmes is the
founder of Jezebel.
ANNA HOLMES: Oh, OK.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
So congratulations.
ANNA HOLMES: I
don't Google myself.
RICHARD GINGRAS: No, that's--
ANNA HOLMES: I like Google,
but I don't Google myself.
RICHARD GINGRAS: You really
should put that on your resume.
ANNA HOLMES: OK. [LAUGH]
RICHARD GINGRAS: So, but let's
start talking, first of all,
about the creation
of Jezebel itself.
And before I do, I think
appropriate context.
When I was going
through the book,
I came upon the definition
for lady journalist, which
has four definitions,
and I'll read the four.
One, thin, pretty,
30-something woman
who is sometimes allowed
to handle the less
hard-hitting television news.
Two, a writer capable
of covering fashion,
celebrity gossip,
and the mommy wars
who's better off leaving
long-form investigative
reporting to more
qualified colleagues.
Three, just like
regular journalists,
only without the awards.
And four, a smart,
tough woman who
loves news enough to fight
through all that bullshit
and do it anyway.
ANNA HOLMES: Hmm.
RICHARD GINGRAS: And it
seemed, quite frankly,
that number four is you.
ANNA HOLMES: Oh.
Thanks.
RICHARD GINGRAS: So
tell us about that,
because I'm sure creating
Jezebel was filled
with complexities
and challenges.
I'd love to hear the story.
ANNA HOLMES: OK.
I'll tell you the story a bit.
If it goes on too long
than you should-- because--
RICHARD GINGRAS: Feel free to--
ANNA HOLMES: --it
could be a long story.
I guess I should
start with the fact
that I had worked
at women's magazines
before I started the site.
And when I say
women's magazines,
I mean women's
service magazines,
such as "Glamour"
and "In Style."
I also worked at
"Celebrity" magazines.
Sometimes those two
things intersect, women's
magazines and
celebrity magazines.
And that was more just
kind of a function.
That wasn't so much my interest.
But that's where the jobs
were in New York in media.
And a lot of my
other female friends,
who may be arrived in New
York and thought oh, we
want to work for "Harper's,"
or "The Atlantic," or "The New
Yorker," found ourselves
working in much more
commercial publications,
a lot of which
we didn't like or agree with.
That was me.
I wouldn't say that I
hated celebrity news,
I just was kind of ambivalent
about it or bored by it.
And with regards to
women's magazines,
I actively hated them, because I
felt that they were patronizing
and were repeating
the same messages over
and over and over again
to young women, which
were along the
lines of be obsessed
with men, romantically.
Thereby, totally pushing out
women who were not interested
in men, so they were
very heteronormative.
They were about finding a man--
and I said this line a lot,
so if you're heard it, you're
going to hear it again.
So they were about finding
a man, keeping a man,
pleasing a man, making
sure he doesn't leave you
for another woman.
Not really about women
and what they wanted,
but women being afraid of
losing things at all times.
And also they were very obsessed
with physical appearance,
and dieting, and
so on and so forth.
And it's just so snooze
worthy, and it was offensive.
Because I could be a 32-year-old
and think that I had some sort
of buffer against the messages
that were being communicated
in these magazines, and maybe
I did, and maybe I didn't.
But I knew for a fact that
there were younger women who
were probably more influenced by
those messages in the same way
that maybe I had been when
I had been 18 or 20 or 22.
So I really hated all the jobs
I had at women's magazines,
because I felt like I
was part of the problem.
But I needed to pay my rent.
I couldn't be like oh, I'm
going to go write a novel.
And at the time
that Jezebel first
started getting discussed,
it was late 2006
and I was working at "In
Style," which of all the women's
magazines I'd worked for,
was the least offensive
because it was pretty
straightforward.
It was about there would
be a celebrity on the cover
and there would be an
interview with her.
And maybe some pictures
from her house, and then
someone else's house
further in the magazine.
And maybe a spread
of the dresses
for spring and maybe
some makeup tips.
I mean that was much
less offensive to me
than how to lose 30
pounds in 30 days,
or how to use a hair
scrunchie in a sex act.
That sort of stuff.
So "In Style" was
actually, again,
pretty inoffensive,
so I wasn't as riled
up about women's
magazines as I had been.
But in late 2006
there was a woman
I'd worked with at a
celebrity magazine, who
was my friend, who was
friends with Nick Denton.
And Nick Denton
owns Gawker Media.
And he wanted her to start what
he was calling girly gawker.
That was a placeholder
name, I think.
One of his colleagues is
over here in the front row.
So I'm pretty sure girly
gawker was a placeholder name.
So the friend of
mine, Geraldine,
asked me if I'd be
interested in working
on this project with her,
and I said no, immediately.
The first thing I said
was no, no, no, no, no.
Because I was a consumer
of the internet,
in the sense that I bought
things on Amazon or eBay.
I read the internet, and then
I read "The New York Times"
online, or I read
CNN.com, or I read
"Gawker," or any
number of blogs.
But is was still not an
environment in which people
in mainstream media
or print media,
they were not moving over
to the internet, really,
at least the ones that
I knew, and because they
weren't getting paid well.
And the whole knock
against Gawker Media,
up until that
point, was that they
didn't pay people very well.
They were paying bloggers
maybe $12 a post.
And at the time I was
34 and I was probably
making $80,000, $90,000 as
an editor at "In Style,"
and there was no way I was
going to take a job that
was going to pay me half that.
I didn't have a trust
fund, unfortunately.
So, I said, no,
but then we spent
about two hours talking
about what it could be.
And in this iteration, it was
to be very celebrity focused.
So we just figured we'd
make snarky comments
about celebrity culture.
She then decided,
Geraldine the friend,
to not work on the
site, for reasons
that are somewhat
unknown to me, but it
had to do with her wanting
to go back home to England
to be closer to her family.
And so I was asked by Nick
Denton and his deputy-- Well,
I guess I wasn't asked.
It's they told me that I was
going to be running or starting
this on my own.
And at that point,
maybe the parameters
had been broadened beyond
celebrity to include fashion.
And I thought, OK, I can
oversee media property that
covers that stuff
because I've certainly
worked within those
genres before,
but I find the way that they've
been presented in the past
to be offensive.
And so I wanted to
create a women's site
that would incorporate
those topics,
but not focus on
them exclusively.
That would treat them or
present them in a smart way.
That would not purport
to tell the readers
who or what they should be.
Would not promote
conspicuous consumption.
Because I really felt, at that
time, in 2006, 2007, so many
of these magazines were all
about $1,000 Louis Vuitton
purses.
And it was like a
frenzy of acquisition.
It was crazy, and I
found it offensive,
and most people can't
afford that stuff,
or oftentimes they were spending
their paychecks on crap.
And I just felt women were
really being ill-served.
I kind of felt it was tied into
the "Sex In The City" stuff.
This like obsession with
name brands and luxury goods.
I found it really gross.
So when I was conceiving
of what this site would be,
it was pretty simple.
It was that it would be
something I'd want to read,
and it would be a kind of
rebuke to women's magazines,
because the whole kind ethos
of Gawker Media at that time
was that their sites
when after the big boys.
So Gawker itself went
after large media companies
on a regular basis, like
Conde Nast, and Time Inc.,
and Hearst.
ESPN was in the
crosshairs of Deadspin.
Apple was often being
taunted by Gizmodo.
So it made sense that we would
go after women's magazines.
And I felt that I
knew just the way
to do it because I had a lot
of decades of frustration
with them pent up.
But in addition to that, that
would kind of announce what
we weren't, which is to say
to go after women's magazines,
but announce what we
were not going to be.
But we would also have
content that you didn't often
find in women's
magazines, like politics,
and a vibrant kind of
constant repetitive discussion
of politics, whether that's
electoral politics or gender
politics.
Because all the women
I knew did not just
want to talk about
fashion and celebrity.
They were much more
diverse and well-rounded.
And in terms of diversity,
that was another thing that
had bugged me, which
was that the world
I lived in, and granted
I lived in New York,
which is a very diverse city.
But the world I lived
in was not reflected
on the pages of
women's magazines
or even in a lot of media.
It was very, very, very white.
And I am not white,
and I felt that was--
I don't know if I'd use
the word offensive--
but it wasn't in
keeping with the times,
because it was, at that point,
2007, and I was seeing a lot
more-- Everything felt more
global and diverse than it had,
let's say, when I'd been
growing up in Davis in the '70s.
But I wasn't seeing
that reflected
on TV very much
and in magazines.
So that's kind of a
long story, or what
I was thinking about
doing when we were putting
the site together, and
conceiving what kind
of features would be on
there, and when it got named,
[LAUGH] by Gabi, who's
sitting in the front row,
and I hated the name.
I wouldn't really use the name.
I wouldn't admit to the name
of the site to people publicly.
Even like a year later, I
just kind of for some reason
it rubbed me the wrong way.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Did its
success surprise you?
What were your expectations
when you went in?
ANNA HOLMES: That's
a good question.
Well, I mean I
felt that I was-- I
went into it with a
feeling of a little bit,
like I was kind of
holding my breath.
Because first of
all, I hadn't been
planning to start
the site on my own.
I thought I was going
to do it with my friend,
and then she drops
out, so now it's on me.
And I was well aware of the
fact that New York media
people read Gawker sites.
And that might be a
tiny little population,
but their opinion
mattered to me.
And therefore, the site had
to succeed, because if it
didn't, then it would be on me.
And this would be the
first time my name had ever
been at the top of something.
And I really felt that I had
control over whether or not
it succeeded.
And the way I could
control that was
that I could just work
my butt off on it.
So that even if
it didn't succeed,
at least I would know
that I had given my all.
And that translated into
me working 18 hours a day
and eventually
getting burned out
three and a half years later.
But I had to suspect
that there were
other women my age,
or younger, or older
who were also frustrated
and felt ill-served
by women's media.
I didn't know that
for a fact, but I
had to assume that they existed,
and that they weren't just
exactly like me
and my peer group,
but that they were
all over the country
and maybe all over the world.
But I wasn't sure that
it was going to work.
There were some naysayers
who-- I wouldn't
say they were-- maybe they
were just being pessimistic.
But there were some
naysayers within the company,
who are my friends,
who weren't sure
after they saw some of
the test blogs, which
is to say us doing the
site, but behind a firewall,
if that's the right word,
before it went live.
Who kind of went
eh, I don't know,
because they hadn't seen
anything like that before,
and I guess I hadn't either.
So I wasn't at all confident
that it was going to succeed,
but it was one of the only
times in my life, I think,
when not only when I had
total control over something,
but that I had to
really just believe.
And it sounds corny,
but believe in myself,
or believe that other people
would-- that if I built it,
they would come.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Can you touch
a little bit on the mechanics,
because, obviously, folks
here, we don't do editorial.
How big was the team
when you started?
And how was it constructed?
How many pieces a day?
How did you deal
with, as you said,
were you paying
people $12 a post?
ANNA HOLMES: No.
Oh yeah, one thing I
didn't say, the reason
I decided to do it was
because the editorial director
of the company told me how
much he would pay me per year,
and he was going to match my
salary, my "In Style" salary.
And I was like, OK, well
that changes things.
Because, again, I don't
want to go backwards.
That said, at the time, they
didn't have health insurance
or benefits, the company didn't.
So I was losing
out a little bit,
but it wasn't-- I think I was
still under the impression that
I would never get sick.
Oh, it's OK-- I
don't have to have
health insurance
for a year or so.
So was really what made
me decide to go for it.
But how was it constructed.
Well, I was given a budget and I
was allowed to hire two people.
So I hired one woman, Moe, in
maybe March or April of 2007.
And then the next staffer,
Jennifer, maybe a month later.
And that was actually
one of the most fun
times on the site was
sitting around mostly
with Moe, whose real
name is Maureen,
and just thinking of ideas and
different features we would do.
Because were going to
blog, which is to say,
put up posts that were
reacting to the news of the day
that we couldn't predict.
But also, we wanted to have
kind of standalone features
that we could count on.
And I feel like we got
paid to sit around and have
awesome ideas.
It was really great, and
made us excited for the site
to actually launch.
So once it launched,
there were three of us.
I did write probably
four or five posts a day
because there were
only three of us,
and we were trying to post
once every half an hour or so.
As the site got
bigger, and I really
don't if I can pinpoint
when it got bigger.
But it was successful
pretty quickly,
in that it got attention,
and it was getting press,
and there were readers
and they were commenting.
And it seemed like
something was going on.
But about a month
after the launch,
I got to hire somebody else.
And then I got to
hire somebody else.
And by, I'd say, Fall of 2007,
I had maybe five people total.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Plus
freelance, I imagine.
ANNA HOLMES: Yeah.
I think I still wasn't
willing to use freelancers
that much then just because
we didn't have a big budget.
And because I knew that I could
count on these five people
that I had.
They were easier to deal with.
Like they were easier
to anticipate what
their various quirks, and
neuroses, and writing styles
were like.
And so I'd say that
by a couple months in,
we were posting once
every 20 minutes.
It became very neurotic about
scheduling because there
was so much going on,
that we had to comment on,
and I wanted it done
in a certain order.
And in order to keep
my brain from melting,
I would have us post every 20
minutes or every 10 minutes.
So you'd see a
little time stamp,
it would say 9 o'clock, 9:10.
When I could have just posted
it whenever it was done
and I'd edited it.
But for some reason, that
added some order to the chaos.
And I'd say by the
second or third year,
we were posting 70
to 80 things a day,
which meant that
there were things
going up every 5 or 10 minutes.
But it was very
highly scheduled,
in that things had to
balance each other out.
So the first post that went
up every day was at 9:00.
I would get up at six, and I
would start finding stories
for the writers
to consider doing.
And they would usually get
online at like 7:00, 7:30.
We all worked remotely
from our apartments.
So they would get online.
I'd see them come on IM, and
then we'd have a little chat,
and I'd send them stories
that they could consider.
So the first post was
always a gossip roundup.
And then the next
post was always
something like the news
of the day-- it could
have been like
something hard-newsy.
The next post after that
was usually about politics,
and I know politics and hard
news can be the same thing,
but I tried to
keep them separate,
at least in those two posts.
And then the next one
would be about a party that
had happened the night
before, and the writer
would be evaluating the
outfits at some party,
that she had not been to.
But Like some movie premiere
with starlets and stuff.
And so I tried to balance out
the topics-- something serious,
something superficial,
something serious.
But also we would put
pictures in between the posts,
as kind of breathing
room, like interstitial.
So I guess the best
way to describe
it is, I had a grad student
come sit with me for three weeks
and watch me work for
a paper she was doing,
and she described it as I was
an air traffic controller.
I feel like that was
a good summation.
I was trying to not
have planes crash.
Not that it was really-- I
mean that's kind of hyperbole
because no one was
going to get hurt.
But it did feel like there were
a lot of things happening all
at once, and the
writers were IM'ing me,
and I'm looking at an RSS
feed, and then Facebook,
and my emails, and there's the
TV on next to me so I can see
if something-- if Kathy Lee says
something stupid on the "Today
Show" so I can clip it.
And it was crazy.
It was totally crazy.
RICHARD GINGRAS: I was tracking
your numbers then, and--
ANNA HOLMES: You were?
RICHARD GINGRAS: --you built
an audience very quickly.
Well, Gawker, I have a
lot of regard Gawker.
I mean there are some folks who
are critical of their sites,
others are not.
But frankly, Nick
and the larger team
have come up with properties
that have worked, and have been
successful, and
actually make money.
ANNA HOLMES: Uh-huh.
RICHARD GINGRAS: But there's
different kinds of impact.
Do you have a sense of
what the impact of Jezebel
has been on traditional media,
particularly women's media?
Can you assess that?
ANNA HOLMES: No.
I mean people tell me,
but I can't assess it
for a couple of reasons.
It might be
reluctance, because I
think that if I say
what I really suspect,
and that's somehow
self-aggrandizing.
Or it could be the
fact is that I feel,
even though I don't
run the site, still
too in the midst of it.
I can look back and say,
yes, something was happening
between 2007 and 2010,
the time that I was there,
that I saw being reflected.
Whether it was kind of
copycat sites-- and I
don't mean that in
an insulting way.
But women sites that
popped up that were
similar in nature and in tone
that came after us that I felt
were kind of
imitating our style.
Or things I was
seeing in the culture,
in the larger, whether
it was popular culture
or whether it was the
fact that I was seeing
more discussion
of gender politics
and feminism in mainstream
media where I had not really
seen that before.
And I could suspect that
maybe that was because of what
my writers were
doing, and that they
were getting a lot of attention.
But there was no way
for me to quantify.
I had no proof.
It was just kind of a feeling.
And I think I was reluctant
to make a direct connection
because it is and was
entirely possible that we just
came around at a certain
time when there was a ground
swell or a hunger for
that sort of content
and we rode a wave,
as opposed to we're
the earthquake that
started the wave.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Like I said,
the local properties, there
are fans, there are non-fans.
I mean I've been a daily reader
of Jezebel from the beginning.
ANNA HOLMES: Really?
RICHARD GINGRAS: I have been,
absolutely, to this day.
Even though, it's not
as when you ran it.
I have to say that, right?
But--
ANNA HOLMES: It's bigger.
RICHARD GINGRAS: But I'm a
guy, and I'm not, obviously,
the target demo.
The feminist
blogosphere, Jezebel
can be a bit contentious.
Is it a feminist
blog, or is it not?
What are your
thoughts about that,
in a relationship with
Jezebel to feminism?
ANNA HOLMES: I never called
it publicly a feminist
blog because that was,
I felt unfair to what
I think are actual
feminist blogs.
And by that I mean not for
profit, labors of love,
done by a person or persons that
are very activist in nature,
and whose content
is solely focused
on the discussion of
feminism and gender politics.
I felt that they deserved
that kind of definition,
and that I wasn't going to
announce that Jezebel was that
because we weren't.
I mean there's a certain
tension between talking
about serious subjects,
like gender politics
and making money, I
don't think that they
are in total conflict.
But in the end, we
were still a site
that was commercial in nature.
It may have been a labor of
love, but I being paid for it,
and so was everybody else.
And the expectation
was that we would grow,
and advertisers would
advertise, and there
was a whole other element there.
So that's why I didn't want
to use the term feminist blog,
but I don't have a problem
with the word feminist.
Quite the contrary.
Part of my
frustration growing up
had been that my peers, from a
very young age-- and by peers,
I mean my female peers-- had
been very reluctant to define
themselves or call
themselves feminists,
even if they agreed
with its basic goals.
And I think that that's because
the word had been dirtied up,
especially during my
childhood, during the '80s
and in the '90s by
a variety of people.
I think that it came
to mean something
that was far more radical
and hard to swallow
than what it really was.
And I guess I never had a
problem describing myself
as a feminist because my
mother always described herself
as a feminist.
So I had that as a role model.
And as I got older, and I
realized that not everyone was
as open to talking
about feminism
or embracing it as I was,
I became very frustrated.
And I think that was the
case with women's magazines.
They just didn't
get that political.
So with the site, we
weren't a feminist blog,
but we were going to
talk about all the time.
And talk about it in an
unapologetic and repetitive
way.
I felt that people tiptoed
around the word in the same way
that they tiptoed around
the word abortion,
or that they tiptoe
around the word rape,
because these are
all things that
might make people uncomfortable.
And so we would not only
talk about those things,
but we would use them
regularly in headlines,
when appropriate
and without apology.
That we would kind of
model to the readers
that there was
nothing to be ashamed
of or there was no reason
to be tiptoeing around a lot
these more difficult subjects.
So people thought of us
as being a feminist blog,
but I never would, again,
would have publicly said that.
I would have said oh, we're
a women's site with where
we try to take a progressive
look at the culture
through pop culture.
And we tried to use pop culture,
and fashion, and celebrity
as entry points into
more serious discussions.
That was really the
ultimate goal of the site.
In my like most ambitious, and
perhaps, bone-headed moments,
I thought, well, we're
going to politicize
a population of young
women who maybe haven't
thought about these
things, or been
privy to these conversations.
And we're going to
do it because they're
going to come to
look at pictures
of Misha Barton walking
down an LA street,
and they're going to
stay because they're
going to be interested in
the post that comes after it.
And they're going to be
interested in not only the way
the writer constructs the post
and the language that she uses,
which is often humor,
but the conversations
and the comments that follow.
And that was an
interesting thing
is that I do feel a lot of
the readers got politicized,
and it wasn't just the work
of myself or the writers,
it was oftentimes
the other readers.
Because I do think that people
are reluctant to be lectured.
And so I don't think we did
any lecturing in the posts.
And I do feel like
the readers were more,
because they had created
such a community,
that they were much more
likely, in many instances,
to listen to one another.
So sometimes we
would put up a post
where we would leave
stuff out on purpose.
I don't mean like
leave a fact out,
but just the discussion wouldn't
be as nuanced or as detailed
as it could have been because
it gave the commenters something
meaty to chew on and
talk about themselves.
And that was really exciting.
But I do think that
we did politicize
a lot of young women.
I don't know what a lot is.
I mean I can't get numbers.
But and I was hoping
we would do that.
And I thought that
by using, again,
these kind of more
accessible topics,
like pop culture or
celebrity culture,
that we could do just that.
RICHARD GINGRAS: I'm
interested to hear
you talk about the tone.
I'm always fascinated with the
art and science of crafting
the right tone for a site,
and you managed to do that.
But I want to move
on to the book,
because I want to make sure
we talk about in the book,
and also make sure we have
time for questions from folks.
Also, a plug for the book,
it's available outside the door
for the heavily Google-y
subsidized price of $10.
ANNA HOLMES: Yeah.
RICHARD GINGRAS: It's
a beautiful book.
ANNA HOLMES: They really
subsidized it. [LAUGH]
RICHARD GINGRAS: Superb paper.
Really nice.
ANNA HOLMES: I'm very grateful.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Buy a bunch.
Give them as gifts to friends.
ANNA HOLMES: Yes.
RICHARD GINGRAS: So
I've got to tell you.
I got the book last week.
I opened it up for the first
time to a page in the letter P.
And the first entry that
hit me was patriarchy.
ANNA HOLMES: Ah, I thought
you were going to say penis.
RICHARD GINGRAS: --whose
definition was "smash it."
So my only question
there, I didn't
realize that Amazon
had the technology
to detect my gender
on a book and cause
me to open to a specific page.
ANNA HOLMES: Uh-huh, uh-huh.
Yeah, I'm impressed too.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Very clever.
ANNA HOLMES: You should
join forces with them.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
You pulled that off.
ANNA HOLMES: [LAUGH]
RICHARD GINGRAS: But
it's encyclopedia.
And I think it's an interesting
format that you chose.
I think there's a
fine history of that,
from whether it's John
Stuart's wonderful textbook,
"A Citizen's Guide
to Democracy,"
or you could, frankly,
go back to Ambrose Bierce
and "The Devil's Dictionary,"
which is one of my favorite.
By the way, its
definition for apology
was to lay the foundation
for a future offense.
[LAUGHTER]
ANNA HOLMES: I like that.
RICHARD GINGRAS: So what caused
you to choose the format?
ANNA HOLMES: Well, that wasn't
the first book idea that I had.
The first idea I had, and
I'm so glad it didn't happen.
But at the time,
this is in 2010,
I was still obsessed
with Sarah Palin.
She really got under my
skin, and had since 2008.
I mean if you go back
and look at the posts
on the site in 2008, there was
at least one or two posts a day
just going after her,
after she got nominated.
I was like I just couldn't deal.
And so it got channeled
into my writers.
So I was like let's do a
book from Sarah Palin's point
of view that's like
making fun of her.
And I wanted to do a yearbook.
It would yearbook format,
and it would be Sarah Palin's
yearbook, and the high
school would be DC.
So the principal was Obama,
and the vice president or vice
principal was Biden, and
she was one of the juniors.
And it would be
a yearbook format
that she would have
written in, her friends
would have written
in, but ultimately, it
would have been
making fun of her.
Now, I still think that
could maybe have worked,
but we were not comedy writers.
We could be funny, but you need
"Mad" magazine to pull that
off, because every single
thing in the book like that
has to be funny.
And we just couldn't execute
that, so that got shelved.
Also good, because if that
had actually gone forward
and that had come
out now, everyone
would have been
like Sarah Palin?
Who cares.
She's just became much
more irrelevant, thank God.
So then I thought,
OK, how can we
sum up the sensibility
of the site into a book?
And I like reference books.
I like sitting around reading
atlas's, and dictionaries,
and encyclopedias.
And I also have
very fond memories
of sitting in my bed,
as a kid, reading
I think it was a set of
Golden Book encyclopedias.
I think it was
children's encyclopedias,
with lots of pictures
about space or [INAUDIBLE]
or what have you.
So I thought why don't we do
an encyclopedia of the world
according to the
sensibility of the site.
And that seemed to be OK with
everyone else who was involved
in the concept,
and the execution,
and the selling of the book.
I also kind of
wanted to preserve,
in printed form, the site,
at least when I had run it.
Like have something
tangible that would last,
because blogs are so ephemeral.
And I would meet people
who had read the site,
or I would talk
to former staffers
and we would reminisce
about the post
that Moe did about--
I'm actually not going
to say what it was because
it was really gross.
But we would have very fun
discussions about posts
that had been put up on the
site that had made a splash
or that we just loved.
And I wanted to, again, have
a permanent piece of the site.
And I don't think
the book is only
reflective of 2007 to 2010.
There's a lot of stuff
from the current iteration
of the site in there.
But that's what I
know best is that era.
And I think the things that
are missing in the book,
and there are many of
them that I forgot about
or I realized too late, are
totally indicative of where
my head is at at
any given moment,
or the pop culture products
that are on my radar.
And so when someone
the other day
asked me, why don't you
have Lauryn Hill in there?
And I was like,
yeah, right, I don't
have Lauryn Hill in there.
But maybe that's because
Lauryn Hill was--
RICHARD GINGRAS: She
just got out of jail.
ANNA HOLMES: Well, I
know she'd been in jail,
where she was off-- She
wasn't in my consciousness.
And I really did try to
remember, think of everything,
but that was kind of impossible.
So maybe there'll
be a second edition.
RICHARD GINGRAS: I
mean a lot of the stuff
was written just for the book.
ANNA HOLMES: It was all
written just for the book.
Yeah.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Right, OK.
And you had a very
impressive stable
of contributors, a
lot of great writers.
ANNA HOLMES: A lot of them
had been staffers on the site,
or were current
staffers of the site,
or had been contributors
in some way,
or had just been in
that genre of lady blogs
and I liked their work.
But it really was I
did not write the book.
I wrote like maybe 20 entries,
and there's 1,000 in there.
I oversaw the
whole thing, but it
was the writers who-- they
were given assignments
and they executed
them very well.
And I think you
can tell that there
are different voices in there.
But it also depends on the
post, because a post about Sarah
Palin is going to be somewhat
jokey and mean-spirited, as
opposed to a post about Planned
Parenthood, which is actually
quite straightforward about the
history of how it came to be.
RICHARD GINGRAS: One
of my reactions to it
was I would start an entry sort
of expecting kind of a jokey
and snarky, and instead
I'll get something serious.
And you kind of
whip-lashed me every time--
ANNA HOLMES: Sorry.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
[INERPOSING VOICES],
which was cool.
But the format, I
think, one thing I love,
I think the format makes
it much more accessible.
It's not a tone that you
feel somehow a responsibility
to read, and just for
a reluctance to start.
You can just play with it.
ANNA HOLMES: You
can flip around.
And there's also pictures,
which I think makes it fun.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Yeah.
ANNA HOLMES: And
that's what I wanted.
I wanted to have
a lot of visuals
to it, just because I
really like pictures.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Buy the
physical book in this case.
ANNA HOLMES: It's
better than eBook.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Much
more fun than the eBook.
ANNA HOLMES: It is.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
Let's go to questions.
AUDIENCE: I want to ask
you just about the tone
of the website itself.
Did you intentionally
set out to be snarky,
because that's the Gawker voice.
And did you mean to be
mean to everybody or just
some select few?
ANNA HOLMES: I don't think
we were mean to everybody.
I think we were just mean to
women's magazines, fashion
designers who are
assholes, Republicans.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: And that
would be people
that maybe you
personally didn't like,
or just all Republicans, all--
ANNA HOLMES: At that point,
pretty much all Republicans,
because they were bananas
then, and they kind of still
are, at least the Party.
I'm not saying civilian
Republicans are all bananas.
We could have been
more fair about things,
but we all had a
similar point of view.
And a lot of what was underlying
the tone on those posts
was anger.
And I think it was often
channeled into humor,
because I do think that
a lot of great humor
comes from an angry place,
or a sense of frustration
with the world and how
society is structured.
But when a post had to be
angry, it was just angry.
And when it maybe
needed some humor
because there was really
nothing else you could do.
Like, for example,
there's no way
to really get angry about
Congresswoman Michele Bachmann,
because she's ridiculous.
So you just made
fun of her. [LAUGH]
Whereas, I think it's much more
legitimate to get angry at,
for our purposes, the assault
on reproductive rights going on
throughout various legislatures
around the country.
Yes, you can make jokes
about stupid stuff
that politicians say.
But the underlying reality of
what was going, is going on,
was not something that
was easy to joke about.
But it's funny, because Gawker
was known for being snarky.
So that was a lot of it.
And also, it just happened,
like the first person I hired,
Moe Tkacik, is very pointed,
and biting, and very,
very brilliant, and can be
extremely mean, and very funny.
And because she
was the first hire,
I feel like she also
set a certain tone.
Because I wouldn't describe
myself as a funny writer.
I can appreciate good humor, and
maybe I can be funny sometimes,
but there's no way-- that
the humor on the site
was not being channeled for me.
It really was thanks to
the specific writers.
And, again, Gawker's
overall kind of snark.
AUDIENCE: But it sounds like
you did have some issues
that you take seriously and
that you kind of campaigned
on inverted commas.
ANNA HOLMES: Yeah.
Every single day.
Yeah.
There was a different
tone to every post,
but it also depended
on who wrote it.
And I think one of the great
things that Gawker did,
and this was maybe a month after
the site launched, was they
put bylines on posts,
across all their blogs.
Before then there
had been no bylines,
so you never knew
which of the writers
was writing what on
any of the sites.
And then you would see
things, like on gawker.com
specifically, a use
of the royal "we."
I feel like maybe the tone
was more, not coherent,
but cohesive, because
there was no way
to distinguish which of the
Gawker editors or writers
was writing any
particular thing.
And once we got by bylines,
then I just let the writers go.
Because also, they were
working really hard.
They worked 10 hours
a day, nonstop.
They would have to
read multiple articles
and process them in their
head, and then somehow spit
them back out in a
well-written funny way.
And do all that within
the course of 45 minutes,
and then I'd edit
it and put it up,
and then they'd do it
again, like over and over
and over and over again.
So there was no way
that I was going
to be able to edit
them into a royal "we."
But also, they would
have resented it,
because I was asking
so much of them that I
had to let them write
in their own voice
and write the things
they wanted to write.
Otherwise, I would have
had a miserable staff.
And I was, again, asking
so much of them already.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Who's next?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So with your writers
working 10 hours a day,
it sounds like there was
a huge push for quantity.
So were you trying to, i
producing so many articles,
just have broader
appeal to your readers,
or just by the nature of a
website looking for traffic?
And if so, did
that ever worry you
about the erosion of the
quality of the articles?
ANNA HOLMES: No
one ever pushed me
to have-- I think if I
had gone to Nick Denton
and say, how many posts are
we supposed to put up a day?
He would've just
said, eh, 20 or so.
I mean I was putting up 70.
And that was not
because he told me to
or anyone else told me to.
It was because we wanted
to cover a lot of ground.
We felt extremely
energized and excited.
And then the more successful the
site got, the more crazy I got.
Which I don't mean that
in a negative way so much.
But if we were getting
a certain result
and I was working
at 200% capacity,
then I figured if I
worked at 300% capacity
I'd get a different result.
And there was this
energy that made us,
or me-- I should just
say me-- made me,
and then, therefore, make the
staffers work even harder.
But we were getting stuff
back from the readers.
It wasn't like we were
putting stuff out there
and it was just
dying on the vine.
I mean it felt like there
was this incredible momentum.
And there was so
much to talk about,
that it felt very
heady and awesome.
But yeah, there were
certainly pressures
to hit certain traffic
goals, but I didn't really
worry about them that much
because we always hit them,
for the most part.
I mean the site
was just growing.
There was some
months, maybe, when
it would grow a little less.
But I never had, from
what I remember--
I mean I could go back and
look at traffic stats--
but I don't remember
there ever being a dip
or where I was taken
aside and someone said,
you need to fix something
because the traffic's not
going up.
I mean at one point, when Gawker
Media was using page views
as the metric by which people
were judged, before they switch
to unique visitors.
I think it was in 2008.
And it became clear
that we were going
to out-do gawker.com
in page views.
And gawker.com had been
around-- when did it start?
2004?
RICHARD GINGRAS: Um-hmm.
ANNA HOLMES: 2002?
OK.
So Gawker had been
around for six years
and was a big well-known
media property,
and we were going to
out-do them in page views
within two year of our launch.
RICHARD GINGRAS: In
fact, in January 2010,
you did about four million
page views to Gawker's 2.7.
ANNA HOLMES: Yeah.
[LAUGH]
RICHARD GINGRAS:
And your edit staff
generated about four million--
ANNA HOLMES: Are you
sure that's page views,
because I feel like
we had least 30.
That may have been uniques.
Really?
Because I feel like--
RICHARD GINGRAS: No.
This is page views.
Uniques were three
million for Gawker and--
ANNA HOLMES: Because
we were usually--
RICHARD GINGRAS: --two for you.
ANNA HOLMES: --in the 20s, in
like a 20 million, 30 million
page views.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
Maybe this is wrong.
ANNA HOLMES: Well, regardless--
RICHARD GINGRAS: Oh,
I'm sorry, 44 million.
ANNA HOLMES: Yeah, OK.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
I missed a digit.
ANNA HOLMES: [LAUGH] And I was
very competitive with Gawker,
even though they
were a different site
in some respects.
RICHARD GINGRAS: They were
35 million, and you were 44.
ANNA HOLMES: That's right.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Actually,
the 2.76 was-- See,
I did this analysis.
ANNA HOLMES: I wasn't
disbelieving you.
I just felt like--
RICHARD GINGRAS: The
average Jezebel contributor
did four and a half
million page views.
ANNA HOLMES: Ah, OK.
RICHARD GINGRAS: They received
2.75 [INAUDIBLE] there, see?
ANNA HOLMES: So
that's very exciting
when you get that
sort of traffic
and you just want to keep
doing what you're doing
or do it better.
But it made me burnout and a
number of other people burnout.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Not surprising.
Next?
AUDIENCE: You kind of talked
about at the beginning
how when you were
going to Jezebel,
there was a demographic of
women that hadn't been touched.
You wanted to go away from the
material stick, fluffy women
stuff, and talk about
maybe more substantive,
whether it's sassy,
irreverent, whatever.
Once you launched
Jezebel, what did you
learn from a lot of the
viewers or the readers?
Did you get a lot of feedback?
Did a lot of people write in?
Did they like a lot
of that content?
Like this demographic was new
to you, so once you entered it,
what did you learn
from that group?
ANNA HOLMES: When you say did
they like that sort of content,
do you mean the more serious
content, or did they like--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So just the edge of
Jezebel, probably.
That you were
taking bold stands.
That you were maybe talking
about maybe some more serious
things.
ANNA HOLMES: They
didn't write in so much,
but they didn't need to because
they would just comment.
And they were there under every
post within two minutes of it
going up.
And then it would just
snowball from there.
Either they were
talking to us, or they
were talking to each other.
And when I say
talking, that means
having a nice
conversation, or maybe
they were giving us the virtual
finger or what have you.
It ran the gamut.
But what I learned, and, again,
these are the commenters,
I think, modeling for
the other readers.
Because a lot of people
read the site and read
the comments but didn't comment.
But the commenters
were notorious
for being any number of things--
argumentative, pain in the ass,
totally intelligent
and hilarious.
I mean they were great
and they were horrible.
And when I say horrible, just
because I would get annoyed
with them.
They actually weren't
that horrible.
They were modeling in the
comments what I suspected,
which was that when
that 10:30 post went up
about the red carpet for the
premiere of "Meet the Fockers,"
that a well-known commenter
would be saying something funny
about Ben Stiller's tux.
And then literally
a half an hour
later there's a post about
rape in the military.
And she's saying something
incredibly intelligent
about that.
So you saw, within the space
of 15 minutes, 30 minutes,
that they were able to pivot
very deftly and intelligently
between hard and soft,
superficial and serious.
Which is further
underscoring the fact
that women are very
diverse and have opinions.
They can walk and chew
gum at the same time.
So and sometimes
this would be modeled
by the writers themselves.
They did have certain beats.
So it was very unlikely that
the political writer or writers
were going to write
about reality TV.
They may have watched
it, but the kind
of diversity of interest and
versatility was, I think,
modeled the most
in the comments.
And that just, again, I guess
underscored my suspicion
that, again, women can walk
and chew gum at the same time.
But I didn't get
that many emails
unless it was someone angry
that I banned them. [LAUGH]
RICHARD GINGRAS: We're
almost running out of time.
So I want to come back to--
Do you have a question, Anna?
AUDIENCE: My first
question is you expressed
some embarrassment, I think,
about the name of the site
initially, and I was wondering
if you could talk about why.
And my second question--
should I ask it now?
RICHARD GINGRAS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Is thinking about what you
were saying about feminism
and the
version/rejection/repulsion
to the term, the
last time that we
had a presidential election--
well, no, before that-- when
Hillary ran, I remember having
conversations with women
in their late 20s, which
was my age at the time,
and they would say
things like, I just
don't think a woman
can do the job, which
was really, really horrifying.
And I was wondering
what you think about
whether we're ready for
some real female leadership?
Oh, and thanks for coming.
ANNA HOLMES: Oh, thanks.
So the first question, why I
was uncomfortable with the name.
Well, a lot of the Gawker
Media sites had made up names.
I mean Gawker I guess
was the real word,
but Jalopnik is a made up word,
and Gizmodo is a made up word,
or they're combinations
of words put together.
And we were trying to come
up with that sort of name
for the site.
And I still have
notes somewhere where
we were coming up with ideas.
But none of them worked.
And then I think
the reason I didn't
like Jezebel was because
it felt obvious to me,
and also because
it was a real word.
It wasn't something
made up, so it
had a lot of baggage
attached to it.
And I guess I thought the
idea of reclaiming a word that
meant something bad
was too obvious.
It's hard for me to,
even now, articulate,
why I had a problem
with it beyond that.
And then I actually remember
after the site launched,
someone sent us an
email, speak emails,
about the name Jezebel, which
I was well aware of in terms
of the Bible or the
Bette Davis movie.
But I had not been
aware that it was also
a word used to describe
a sexually promiscuous,
highly emotionally
damaged mixed race woman.
And it was used this way in
the Southern part of the United
States.
So it was very racially coded.
Had no idea.
Someone sent me a
Ph.D. paper about this,
and I remember thinking,
this is really bad.
Because I'm mixed race, and
the site is not about me.
And there was a
little avatar, which
was on the cover, which
was a blonde woman.
But that made me feel
very uncomfortable,
because-- I believe the
term is tragic mulatto.
That was what a Jezebel was.
Like a woman who was
a tragic mulatto who
was promiscuous or a slut.
And I really didn't like all
the implications of that.
And I think once I
decided I didn't like it,
I just didn't like it.
I was being stubborn about it.
But yeah, I wouldn't
use the word.
I'd say, and I'd meet
someone and then they'd
say, where do you work?
I'd say I work for a blog.
Oh, what blog?
Well, it's done by Gawker Media.
Oh, what is it about?
It's about women.
What is it called?
But I just let it go
on until I finally
went [FLAT TONE] Jezebel.
[LAUGHTER]
RICHARD GINGRAS: In
the interest of time,
and I want to conflate a second
question with one that I wanted
to get into, which is about
women in leadership positions.
And even notion of women
not necessarily accepting
that they can be in
leadership positions.
So a) why do you do what you do?
How are you comfortable
doing what you're doing?
Who inspired you to--
ANNA HOLMES: Me?
RICHARD GINGRAS: Yeah, you.
ANNA HOLMES: Well, I don't
feel like I'm in a leadership
position right now because--
RICHARD GINGRAS: Not
literally at the moment.
ANNA HOLMES: OK.
RICHARD GINGRAS: But you've
been in a leadership position.
ANNA HOLMES: I don't
know that I ever
had a model of being in
a leadership position,
but I feel like I fell into it.
And that there was
definitely a part of me
that was absolutely terrified
throughout the whole thing,
even when it was you think
I could have put my feet up
and relax.
I was absolutely terrified.
Because I didn't know
how to be a manager.
I had to teach myself
And that's a very
specific type of job.
There's no water cooler.
You're not taking your
employees out to lunch
or shooting the shit.
It's very intense.
I guess I don't know how to
answer that question because I
don't know that I've
thought that much about it.
I certainly am in awe of
women in leadership positions
that are very visible, like
in business or in politics,
whether it be Hillary Clinton or
any number of female senators,
or females of Supreme
Court justices.
I ran into one of them
in DC two days ago.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Who?
Not Ginsburg.
ANNA HOLMES: Elena Kagan.
No, I wish Ginsburg.
Not to diss Kagan. [LAUGH]
RICHARD GINGRAS:
Justice Ginsburg.
ANNA HOLMES: Yeah, yeah.
But I guess I've given women
in leadership positions,
in terms of politics
and business thought,
but as totally apart
from me, but not
so much how it relates
to my own life.
And I think that there's still
a certain amount of inability
to imagine--
Well, I think there's a
certain amount of insecurity
still about what am
I going to do next?
And am I going to be
the boss of something?
And what would that look like?
Even though I've
done that before.
It's not enough to
stop me from doing it,
but it's not like
it comes naturally.
Although, I'm told I was
very bossy as a child.
So maybe it's in my DNA.
But I do think
that a lot of girls
have that socialized out of
them in many complex ways
that I'm not immune to, and that
I have to challenge as well.
So I'm sorry if I'm
avoiding the question,
but it's not one I
have a good answer for.
RICHARD GINGRAS: It's truthful.
ANNA HOLMES: Yeah.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Well,
let's take one more.
What the heck.
AUDIENCE: So for those of
you who are unfamiliar,
Brian Goldberg, who started
Bleacher Report put together
a woman's blog.
And I also read a response
that you had to it.
I, admittedly, haven't
actually looked at Bustle,
so I don't really know
much about the content.
But I'm just wondering if you
had any tips for him, or what--
ANNA HOLMES: Write
something else.
AUDIENCE: --your--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: --response is to that.
ANNA HOLMES: I should
probably put them in context.
Because this young
man got $6 million
in funding to start this
women's website called Bustle,
and then he'd wrote
something that
was published in PandoDaily,
Daily which was a very press
release soundy, in which he
patted himself on the back
for having come up with the
brilliant idea of merging
pop culture and
politics for women.
It was the weirdest-- At
first I had to read it twice
because he was describing
any number of websites that
had been around for a long
time, including Jezebel,
or even magazines that had been
around long before Jezebel came
along.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
[INTERPOSING_VOICES] funding
proposal--
ANNA HOLMES: It
was unbelievable.
RICHARD GINGRAS: --for 1998.
ANNA HOLMES: It is
so self-aggrandizing.
And naive, and tone deaf,
and self-congratulatory,
and it was just weird,
and it made me mad
because it was erasing
the existence of people
who had pioneered that
space long before he had.
It was a bit chest thumpy.
And there's a certain skepticism
among a lot of the people
I know in the media,
especially women,
to Silicon Valley
row chest thumping.
Even though we're not really
privy to it because a lot of us
live in New York.
It was just something that just
really rubbed me the wrong way.
So I wrote a
comment to the post,
along with a number of other
women, that wasn't probably
very nice.
I mean I didn't call him names,
but I was angry about it,
as were a lot of other people.
So what advice would I give him.
Well, the thing is
that he seems to think
that he can build his site
into a powerhouse with,
I don't know-- he was talking
about 50 million uniques
a month.
Like that's what he wants.
Something enormous like that.
And it's very possible
he can do that,
but it's also highly likely that
it's not going to be any good.
Because it sounds
to me that if he
wants to build a site at
that scale with the quickness
that he-- I don't know if it's
supposed in five years or what,
but that it's going to be a lot
of shit throwing at the wall
and seeing what sticks,
as opposed to quality.
And I also don't
know if that really
is a way to build
a community when
there's just stuff everywhere.
One of my problems
with women's media
online, before the
site started, the sites
that were online, like iVillage.
I guess that was for older
women, which is fine.
But I'm not even sure what--
RICHARD GINGRAS: They
weren't older women then.
ANNA HOLMES: It was
just incoherent,
in the same way that the
"Huffington Post" sometimes
can be incoherent.
It's like something--
too much going on.
So if he wants to make an
incoherent media property that
gets 50 million uniques
a month and makes
lots of money for him,
great, but I'm not sure
it's going to be any good.
But my advice to him
would be like shut up.
I don't mean he should
like not start a site.
But he should maybe look at
the space and talk to people
and take in things
before he pops off
like he did in that post.
But I think that he probably
was very chastened by it.
It seemed like he was
very apologetic by it.
And I actually felt sorry
for him after a while,
until "The New Yorker"
article came out,
and then there was
that picture of him
using a woman as a table--
one of his female employees
as a table, on which
he rested his laptop.
And I was like, OK, I don't
feel sorry for you anymore.
[LAUGHTER]
ANNA HOLMES: Yeah.
I actually haven't looked
at that site at all.
I just think I'm not interested.
At some point I'll
go look at it.
Are you bringing it up?
RICHARD GINGRAS:
It's right there.
ANNA HOLMES: Oh.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
It actually managed
to nail national cat day today.
ANNA HOLMES: Wow, OK.
I thought it was uber
national cat day, or is it--
RICHARD GINGRAS: No.
I'm told it's national cat day.
ANNA HOLMES: I
thought you were going
to talk about the
crazy cat lady?
RICHARD GINGRAS: Well, I was.
And since we're not getting
kicked out of the room,
yes, it is national cat day.
I heard somewhere that
your favorite post
was about cat ladies--
ANNA HOLMES: Oh, no no.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Not
post, your entry.
ANNA HOLMES: It's not
my favorite entry.
The thing is that I've looked
at the text in the book
so many times and read the
posts over so many times
that they all kind
of are a blur to me.
And what I like about the
crazy cat lady [INAUDIBLE]
is just an illustration, done
by a San Francisco illustrator,
is that it, like
some other posts,
takes a historically
maligned type of individual,
the crazy cat lady, and honors
her in a very loving way.
Because I would describe
myself as a crazy cat lady.
I don't have eight cats.
I have one.
But just like there's
just certain things
that people who have
pets or cats know.
And that's why I
particularly like that post.
RICHARD GINGRAS:
Well, thank you.
And that's proving, once
again, that all conversations
ultimately get
around back to cats.
ANNA HOLMES: That's
right, on the internet.
Yeah.
RICHARD GINGRAS: So
I thank you usually
for being here with us
today, and more importantly,
for doing what you do.
And--
ANNA HOLMES: Thank you.
RICHARD GINGRAS: I just can't
wait to see what you do next.
ANNA HOLMES: Thank you.
Thanks, Richard.
RICHARD GINGRAS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]